What if after you die part of you goes to heaven part of you stays here
Just to see how things turn out
Windgap there was a murder there another ones missing now get me a story
Hi mama
Goodness I didn't expect you. The house is not up to par for visitors. I'm just in town on business
Camille look at you, I'm glad you're home
What kind person does that? Hurt a child? Doesn't help anything rilin' folks up
You got two mutilated girls on your hands. Someone else is doing the rilin'
When you're here you're my daughter everything you do comes back on me
I didn't come back to cause any problems
I can tell you hate this place like me
Someone in this towns hiding something
Mama says I need to be careful around you
That true?
Are you dangerous?